لن نتوقف قبل استعاده الرهائن كافه هذا هو
عنوان هذه المسيره التي انطلقت من وسط
مدينه القدس وستصل الى قباله المقر الرسمي
لرئيس الوزراء بنيامين نتنياهو يطالبون
بالعمل الفوري من اجل ابران تبقه تبادل
واعاده الاسر الاسرائيليين المحتجزين في
غزه يرفعون صورهم ويرددون الان الان
نريدهم احياء وليس في توافي ويقولون بان
الوقت ينفد على سبيل المثال هذا الشعار
باللغه العبريه يحمل اكثر من معنى من فه
يقول الوقت ينفذ لكن هذه الكلمه تعني ايضا
رحمهم الله وهذا يعبر عن خشيه العائلات من
ان يقتل عدد من الاسر كما حدث مع اخرين في
عمليات عسكريه حاول الجيش
الاسرائيلي تحريرهم من خلالها اذا هذا
الحراك تحديدا هو جزء من مظاهرات ومسيرات
شهدتها مدن عده هذا اليوم داخل اسرائيل
وتنظمها تحديدا حراكات نسائيه يقولون
بانهم يستطيعون التاثير كما حدث
97 عندما قامت ارب امهات لجنود كانوا في
جنوب لبنان وبداوا بحراك سرعان ما اتسع
وادى في نهايه الامر الى انسحاب اسرائيل
من جنوب لبنان في عام 2000 نجوان سمري
الجزيره مدينه القدس اقص